THE IS NOW IN SESSION. DR QUIRK
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
. SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY
. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND.
BENNETT BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. BRIAN
CALDERON. CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHEN. CHOI COOLEY. COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY. DAILY DAVIES
FLORA. MIKE FONG VINCE FONG
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY
LEAD LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK-SILVA
DOMINO'S REYES LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH
STONE TÍNH VELADERO AS THE
APPROVED LAW VOEPEL WALDRON
BOARD WEBER. WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
pASSEMBLY. WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAZE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM ANSWER. IN THE NAME OF
GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. LIFE IS GOD'S GIFT TO
US. WHAT WE DO WITH OUR LIVES IS
OUR GIFT TO GOD. AS WE CHERISH
OUR LIVES. SO WE MADE IT RESPECT
AND NOURISH THE MOST FRAGILE.
THE WEAKEST THE MOST A DESTITUTE
AMONGST. THANKS BE TO THE LIVING
GOD FOR PLACING A SPIRIT OF
SERVICE IN THE HEARTS OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN. OF THIS ASSEMBLY.
THROUGH THEIR WORK CREATE
JUSTICE THAT IS BLIND. BUT THEIR
VOICES RING WITH TRUTH THEIR
LIVES ECHO INTEGRITY. SO BLESSED
AS A DAY. OUR STATE AND THIS
ASSEMBLY TO YOUR SERVICE. A
BEACON OF JUSTICE FOR ALL I MEAN. THANK YOU MA'AM YES SIR WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
LEVY. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. AS. ZERO SAN. IT IS.
STRONG THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY SEAMUS
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
ASSEMBLY MINUTE NINETY AM THE
AUTOMOBILE BONTA SYSTEM SPEAKER
PRO TEM OF THESE IN THE
PRESIDING LOOKS REPORTER THE
DESK REFLECTIVITY BOWMAN READING
WILL CALL THE ROLL CALL MR WARD
MOVES IN MISTER FLORA SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AT PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED. IN THE
JOURNAL. AND MISTER WARD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MCCARTY AGUIAR-CURRY
COOLEY DOLLY GALLAGHER AND WOOD
TO SPEAK ON IN GERMAN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THEORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TO ALLOW SOMEONE MEMBERS
POWER CAME IN AND LEVINE TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY THE GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED AT THEIR DESK. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MISTER SPEAKER THE
GOVERNOR'S STATE OF THE STATE
SPEECH HAS BEEN TRANSMITTED TO
THE ASSEMBLY IT IS AT THE DESK I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PRINT THE ADDRESS AS AN APPENDIX
IN THE JOURNAL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER FINALLY PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY THREE IRWIN FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. AND AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF. SPECIAL GUESTS WITH
US ON THE FLOOR AND IN THE
GALLERY TODAY. WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BARRICADE HAN IS JOINED AT HER
DESK BY HER DAUGHTER GABRIELLE
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT LEVINE IS
JOINED AT HIS DESK BY HIS SON
WYATT WELCOME WHY IT SHOULD BE
ASSEMBLY.
AND ELLEN ARE ROWS. HIGH SCHOOL
. AND THEY ARE GAS- ASSEMBLY
WOMAN CERVANTES WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ALSO HAVE NORCO
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER CATHERINE
ALLEMAN AND EASTVALE CITY
COUNCIL SHOTS YEAH OUR JOINING
US ALSO GUESTS ON ASSEMBLY
MOMENTS. WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
. WE ARE MOVING ON TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. SO READING
THE CLERK WILL. THE BILL TWENTY
TWO S<c.cyan> 418-348-1219 SIXTY TWENTY</c>
THREE OH TWO WITH A MINUTE
SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN ALSO WITH
AMENDMENTS HOUSE WASN'T HOW WITH
A MINUTES AND IT'S BILL TWO
TWENTY WITH AMENDMENTS. ALL
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEM TEN
SHALL BE CONTINUED. ON ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE ITEMS ELEVEN
THROUGH TWENTY FIVE. SHALL BE
PASS AND RETAIN AND ON SENATE
THIRD READING. FILE ITEMS TWENTY
SIX OR TWENTY EIGHT SHALL BE
PASS AND RETAIN. MEMBERS WE DO
HAVE A CONSENSUS CALENDAR.
MEMBERS WE WILL PASS A RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM FORTY. DOES ANY WE'RE
SHERMANAN ITEM THE CAN CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING NINE. THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN OH TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN IMMACULATE IN
THE BUSINESS. AND THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIED UP HI
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. CLERK WILL
READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
CONSENT. ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY
ONE FIFTY FIVE I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO
MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVERAL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON. THE CAN ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT WILL MEET AT TWO
THIRTY PM IN ROOM FOR FORTY
FOUR. THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCE WILL MEET YOU PM IN
ROOM FOUR SAP- COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION WILL MEET
AT TWO THIRTY IN ROOM. ONE
TWENTY SIX. ENTER COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION MEET AT TWO
THIRTY AND SWING SPACE ROOM.
ELEVEN HUNDRED. MEMBERS OF THE
QUORUM CALL IS NOT YET LIFTED.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS
TIME MEMBERS. THE FORM CALL
REMAINS IN PLACE.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS
TIME MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS-
BUT A PURPOSE THAT I GET UP
TODAY AND ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES JUST
A FEW BLOCKS FROM HERE. THIS IS
MY DISTRICT IS THIS IS MY
HOMETOWN BUT THIS IS ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY LITERALLY ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED STEPS FROM WHERE YOU'RE
SITTING RIGHT NOW WAS THE
DEADLIEST MASS SHOOTING IN THE
HISTORY OF SACRAMENTO- THIS
CAN'T BE OUR NEW NORMAL- BUT
TODAY WE WENT TO. CERTAINLY
DISCUSS THE TRAGIC SHOOTING THAT
AGAIN FORTY EIGHT HOURS AGO
RIGHT HERE. A TRAGIC IS TOO
SMALL OF A WORD TO DESCRIBE WHAT
OCCURRED. JUST TWO NIGHTS AGO IT
WAS AS A DEVASTATING LOSS FOR
OUR CITY. DEVASTATING LOSS OF
SIX PEOPLE WO LOST THEIR LIVES
NOW DECEASED TWELVE OTHERS. SHOT
AND WOUNDED WE DON'T KNOW THE
OUTCOMES OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WE DON'T KNOW ALL THE FACTS YET
THIS IS AN ONGOING POLICE
INVESTIGATION THE WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK A PHENOMENAL JOB TO
BRING THE PERPETRATORS TO
JUSTICE. BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
SEVENTY FIVE ROUNDS WERE SHOT
WITHIN FIFTY FOUR SECONDS. THREE
HUNDRED STEPS FROM HERE. ON THE
BALCONY OUTSIDE OF HERE. YOU CAN
SEE THE CRIME TAPE RIGHT OUTSIDE
OF OUR OF OUR STATE CAPITOL. IS
NOT RIGHT IT BREAKS ALL OF OUR
HEARTS COLLECTIVELY. TO SEE
YOUNG PEOPLE RUNNING FOR THEIR
LIVES. TO KNOW THAT INDIVIDUALS
WERE RUNNING LIKE THEY'RE IN A
WAR ZONE LIKE WE'RE SEEING NOW
ON BBC. AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW ALL
THE FACTS SAID ABOUT THE
DECEASED WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY
WERE HAVING A GREAT TIME
INNOCENT BY STANDARDS IF THEY'RE
THE PERPETRATORS. YOU KNOW THERE
IS A FIFTY SEVEN YEAR OLD WOMAN
DOWN OR LACK THAT A TOUGH TIME
IN LIFE OUT THERE SHE WAS TRYING
TO SLEEP AT NIGHT. SHE WAS
GUNNED DOWN. WE'RE GONNA FIND
OUT MORE IN THE DAYS TO COME.
BUT AGAIN MEMBERS I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURNED. IN MEMORY OF THESE
SIX LIVES. AND THE THINK ABOUT
MY CITY MY HOMETOWN. AND WE TAKE
A MOMENT OF SILENCE TO REMEMBER
THIS TRAGEDY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CARTY MEMBERS PLEASE
RISE. AS WE OBSERVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE. FOR THE VICTIMS OF THIS
TRAGEDY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. MEMBERS OF
THE QUORUM CALL REMAINS IN PLACE
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL IN MEMORY
TODAY. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
THE MEMORY OF ONE OF OUR VERY
OWN. FORMER SENATOR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOHN DUNLAP THE CHAMPION
OF PROGRESSIVE CAUCUSES. JOHN
DIED MARCH FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WITH HIS LOVING WIFE MARY
LOU AND HIS CHILDREN BY HIS
SIDE. JOHN'S LIFE SPAN SPAN A
HUNDRED YEARS IN THE HISTORY OF
THE NAPA VALLEY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HIS FAMILY ROOTS RUN
DEEP. JOHN'S GREAT GRANDFATHER
NAY THINK HOMES CAME OVER ONTHE
OREGON TRAIL TO CALIFORNIA AND
FOUNDED THE CITY OF NOW BUT IN
EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN. BORN
SEPTEMBER. ELEVEN NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO TO AMY HOLMES AND
JERRY DUNLAP. JOHN WAS YOUNGEST
OF FOUR SONS AND WAS RAISED ON
THE FAMILY'S PRUNE ORCHARD NEW
YORK BILL HE GROW FROM NAPA
HIGH'S NINETY FORTY SIR FOR YOUR
THE OR DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
GRADUATED FROM UC BERKELEY IN
NINETEEN FORTY SIX BEFORE GOING
ON TO LAW SCHOOL. IN NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE WHILE TRAVELING BY
TRAIN BACK TO THE ARMY BASE
AFTER VISITING HIS PARENTS THE
NAPA HE MET A GIRL NAMED JANET
JACK. HE OFFERED HER THE WINDOW
SEAT AND THEY TALK THROUGHOUT
THE NIGHT. BEFORE THEY PARTED
WAYS HE ASKED FOR HER PHONE
NUMBER. THEY WERE MARRIED IN
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. AFTER THE
WEDDING. IN PENNSYLVANIA THE
COUPLE BRIEF LIVED BRIEFLY IN
SAN FRANCISCO BEFORE MOVING BACK
TO NAPA WHERE JOHN JOINED THE
FAMILY LAW FIRM COMBS AND THAT
OF DUNLAP. WHEN JOHN CAME TO
SACRAMENTO IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN AS PART OF A FOR. CLASS
THAT INCLUDED PETE WILSON.
GEORGE MOSCONI AND RONALD REAGAN
. JOHN REPRESENTED NORTH BAY
COUNTIES IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. AND THEN
IN THE STATE SENATE FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR TO SEVENTY
EIGHT HIS SERVICE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WAS KEEP WITH WAS
KEEPING WITH FAMILY TRADITION.
THOUGH HE WAS A DEMOCRAT WAS
GREAT GRANDFATHER GRANDFATHER
UNCLE RALPH REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
HE AUTHORED LARGE LEGISLATION
AND WORKED WITH THEN JERRY BROWN
TO CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD. WHICH EXTENDED COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS TO FARMWORKERS
. JOHN KERRY LEGISLATION TO BAN
THE USE OF ERA SOULS THERE
BLAMED FOR THE DEPLETION OF THE
OZONE LAYER AND LED THE FIGHT TO
PROTECT THE CALIFORNIA
COASTLINE. ADDITIONALLY HE WAS
THE PRIME MOVER IN THE CAMPAIGN
TO COMPEL STATE GOVERNMENT TO
STOP INVESTING IN COMPANIES WITH
BUSINESS TIES TO SOUTH AFRICA.
WHERE THERE HAVE APARTHEID A
GOVERNMENT DENIED RIGHTS TO THE
BLACK MAJORITY. AFTER SIXTY
YEARS OF MARRIAGE JANET DIED OF
LEUKEMIA AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
FOUR. IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN JOHN
MET MARY LOU KENLEY A. B. IN A
BEREAVEMENT CLASS THEY JOINED
AFTER THE DEATHS OF THEIR
SPOUSES. THEY WERE MARRIED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. I DIDN'T
KNOW IT COULD BE THIS WONDERFUL
TWICE JOHN WOULD SAY LATER.
SINCE JOHN AND MARY LOU SHARED A
PASSION FOR PROGRESSIVE POLITICS
IT WAS ONLY FITTING THAT THEIR
HONEYMOON INCLUDED TOUR OF THE
OBAMA WHITE HOUSE THEY WERE
HONORED AT A FAMILY DINNER AND
SAT COURT SIDE AT A WASHINGTON
MYSTICS BASKETBALL GAME WHERE
MERRILEES NEPHEW COACHES THE W.
NBA. GENERALLY LOVE TO TRAVEL
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD BUT ALSO
LOVE THEIR HOME ENOUGH OF WHERE
THEY WOULD READ OUT LOUD TO EACH
OTHER. THEY PLAYED BOTCHING. AND
WERE ACTIVE MEMBERS OF THE NAPA
VALLEY UNITARIAN UNIVERSALISTS.
JOHN ALSO SPOKE TO THE NAPA
SPOKE TO THE NAPOL HISTORICAL
SOCIETY ABOUT HIS FAMILY'S
HISTORY IN THE COUNTY. IN
ADDITION TO MARY LOU IS SURVIVED
BY FOUR CHILDREN GEN BUT JANE
DUNLAP PETER DUNLAP. DAVID
DUNLAP AND JILL DUNLAP. AND FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN. IS JOIN ME IN
HONOR AND REMEMBER FORMER
SENATOR JOHN DUNLAP AND THEY A
CARING AND COMPASSIONATE MEMBER
OF OUR LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY AND YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
. AND THIS IS MY GOOD FAMILY
FRIEND THAT RECENTLY PASSED I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF JOHN RICHARD JACK GRAFF A
YELLOW COUNTY NATIVE IS THE PORT
OF COACHABLE EDUCATOR AND AN
HONORED VETERAN AND A FRIEND TO
MANY. JACK PASSED AWAY IN THE
COMFORT OF IS HOME SURROUNDED
BY HIS FAMILY ON MARCH NINTH AT
THE AGE OF NINETY TWO. AFTER
GRADUATING FROM WINTERS HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT.
WHERE HE WAS ACTIVE STUDENT AND
SPORTSMAN JACK ATTENDED SANTA
CLARA UNIVERSITY WHERE HE
MAJORED IN POLITICAL SCIENCE
BEFORE JOINING THE UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS. JACK MARRIED
MARJORIE PART POTTER HIS HIGH
SCHOOL SWEETHEART AND THE LOVE
OF HIS LIFE BEFORE LEAVING FOR
THE MARINE CORPS SERVICE. WHEN
YOU RETURN JACK EARNED HIS
TEACHING CREDENTIAL AT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
WHERE HE WOULD GO ON TO EARN HIS
MASTER'S DEGREE IN THE IN
EDUCATION AT U. O. P. SHOWING
pSTUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA JACK
SPENT NEARLY FOUR DECADES IN THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM. WORKING
HIS WAY TO BEING A COACH YUBA
CITY YUBA CITY HIGH SCHOOL TO
BEING A VICE PRINCIPAL AND THEN
PRINCIPAL ABANDONED HIGH SCHOOL
IN BACK OF BILL. ELDORADO HIGH
SCHOOL IN PLACERVILLE IN HIS OWN
ALMA MATER WINNERS HIGH SCHOOL.
HE CONTINUED TO BE COME THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF WINTER SCHOOLS
EVENTUALLY SERVED TWO TERMS AS
THE YELLOW COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS. THAT'S OUT OF
OUTSIDE OF HIS COMMITMENT TO
SCHOOLS THE STUDENTS JACK WAS
DEEPLY INVESTED IN BETTERING HIS
COMMUNITY HE SERVED ON THE
WINNERS PLANNING COMMISSION AND
ST ANTHONY'S PARISH BUILDING
COMMITTEE. HE WAS A MAN THIRTY
YEAR MEMBER OF THE ROTARY CLUB
AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF YELLOW
COUNTY MARINE CORPS DETACHMENT.
AND THE YELLOW COUNTY CIRCUIT
REPRESENTATIVE FOR FOSTER CARE.
AND FOSTER YOUTH. JACK LEAVES
BEHIND HIS WIFE MARGE. FIVE
CHILDREN PATTY PEGGY CAPPY JODY
IN JOHN TWELVE GRANDCHILDREN
THIRTEEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AS
WELL AS NUMEROUS MEMBERS OF HIS
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN REGION A JOURNEY IN
THE MEMORY OF MY GOOD FRIEND
JACK ROUGH A MAN WHOSE
COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION AND
PUBLIC SERVICES TOUCH
GENERATIONS OF YELLOW COUNTY
STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS HE WILL
BE DEEPLY MISSED. THANK YOU IS
AGUIAR-CURRY. AND MISS DALY
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO HONOR A
LONGTIME MEMBER OF THE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY KATHY LYNCH A BELOVED
ADVOCATE WHOSE ABSENCE WILL BE
FELT BY MANY. KATHY STARTED HER
LOBBYING FIRM LYNCH AND
ASSOCIATES IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE HER CLIENTS INCLUDED
BUSINESS AND TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR AND
EDUCATION INTERESTING
CALIFORNIA. PRIOR TO ENTERING
THE WORLD OF PUBLIC POLICY KATHY
WORKED FOR NEW YORK BASED
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANY
WHERE SHE SPECIALIZED IN LABOR
RELATIONS ADMINISTRATION.
KATHLEEN CARED ABOUT THE PEOPLE
SHE SERVED AND THE WORK BEING
DONE IN THIS BUILDING. SHE WILL
BE REMEMBERED FOR HER
SELFLESSNESS GENEROSITY. AND THE
WAY SHE PASSIONATELY ADVOCATED
FOR HER CLIENTS WE LAW KATHY WE
ARE TO SOON AND SHE WILL BE BY
HER FAMILY FRIENDS AND ALL OF US
IN THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY. I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE HER FOR
AND FRIENDS ARE HERE TODAY- TO
HONOR KATHY ENJOY. MY AND
PRAYERS ARE WITH YOU THEY WERE
BRIGHT LIGHTS IN THIS CAPITAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME TODAY AND HONORING
LEE. THANK YOU MISTER ALI AND
MISTER COOL. YOU TOO ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS A GERMAN
MEMORY. COLLEAGUES I AM.
SADDENED BUT HONORED TO RISE IN.
REMEMBRANCE OF KATHY LYNCH I
KNEW HER AS A YOUNG MAN- IN
THOSE DAYS I THINK WHEN I FIRST
MET KATHY SHE WAS. IS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHO'S ACT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION. LONG AGO SHE FEELS
AL COOPER ALVA COOPER AS HE WAS
KNOWN REPRESENT THE INTERESTS
OF. TRUCKERS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
I THINK WHEN I WHEN I THINK OF
CATHARINE. ALL I REMEMBER JUST
HER CHARACTER YOU KNOW. NINETEEN
SEVENTIES THERE WERE ACTUALLY
NOT THAT MANY WOMEN ADVOCATES.
SO SHE WAS DEFINITELY SOMEONE
WHO CAME HERE AND BROKE THE
GLASS CEILING. WITH JUST A
HANDFUL OF OTHER WOMEN LOBBYIST
TRYING TO BE EFFECTIVE ARDENT
ADVOCATES FOR THEIR ISSUES. SHE
WAS SHE WAS WHAT I WOULD CALL
SORT OF A AND PARDON ME
JOURNEYMAN A JOURNEY PERSON SHE
KNEW THE BUSINESS OF ADVOCACY.
SHE WOULD MEET WITH MEMBERS
EXPLAIN HER POSITION TO LISTEN
TO THEM DO HER HOMEWORK AND
PROVIDE FEEDBACK IF THERE WAS
ISSUES RAISED SHE MET WITH
STAFF. SHE WAS AN ARDENT
ADVOCATE IN COMMITTEES SHE TOOK
NOTHING FOR GRANTED. AND SHE HAS
SUCH A WIDE ARRAY OF CLIENTS
OVER YEARS I REMEMBER HER TO
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION. I REMEMBER
EARLY ON WITH THE TIMBER
ASSOCIATION BECAUSE THE
PUBLISHER OF THE SAN MATTEO
TIMES HAD SOME. VANCITY WANTED
TO GET A TIMBER PLAN GOING FOR
RUN INTO PROBLEMS ON THE LAW AND
LOOP HAPPENED WORKED ON THAT-
AND SHE WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
CONVERSATION TRYING TO WORK ON
TEMPERATURES. SHE OF. WAS ALWAYS
ACT WITH THE AMERICAN PEST
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
FOREST AND PAPER ASSOCIATION
AMERICA WOULD COUNCIL WASTE
HAULERS COUNCIL OF GOLDEN STATE
BILL ASSOCIATION WHICH IS
MAINTAINED A LONG HISTORY OF
REPRESENTATION FOR. OFF ROAD
VEHICLE ASSOCIATION OF THE
OUTSTANDING THING ABOUT
CATHERINE LYNCH WAS. SHE WAS
THIS PERSISTENT DETERMINED
ADVOCATE. AND I THINK THAT HAD
TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT SHE
STARTED. AND WOMEN WILL
UNDERSTAND THIS THAT WHEN YOU GO
INTO A MALE DOMINATED PROFESSION
YOUR FIELD YOU KNOW THE EXPENSES
CAN DO EVERYTHING MEN DO AND
HIGH HEELS OF THING YOU HAVE TO
EXCEL AT A HIGHER LEVEL YOU NEED
TO ESTABLISH YOUR BONA FIDE
EIGHTIES. IN KIND OF THE CLUB
NETWORK OF THIS CAPITAL. AND SHE
DID THAT. SHE WAS VERY
DETERMINED. AND CONSEQUENTLY
ENJOYED A LONG CAREER. AND THIS
TEMA HER COLLEAGUES FOR THE WAY
SHE APPROACHES- HER CLIENTS AND
THIS MEANS YOU KNOW YOU LIST A
LIST OF HER HER CLIENTS YOU
REALIZE WITH CATHERINE LYNCH THE
DOORS TO THE STATE CAPITOL WERE
NEVER CLOSE TO ANY OF HER
CLIENTS. SHE FOUND A WAY TO
PERSIST TO BRING THEIR FORD TO
ARTICULATE THEM AND TO ALLOW
DELIBERATION IN THE TWO HOUSES
TO PROCEED ON AN INFORMED BASIS
WHENEVER HER CLIENT'S INTERESTS
FOR RISK OF TO JUST HONOR TO
THINK ABOUT HER TO TAKE A MY
LONG CAREER WITH HER. TO DO
THINK ABOUT THE ENERGY THAT SHE
BROUGHT TO WITH THE INTEGRITY
SHE BROUGHT THE PERSISTENCE OF.
TO MAKE THE PROCESS BETTER AND I
ASKED WE JORDAN HER TREASURED
FAMILY. THANKS AND MR GALLAGHER
YOUR ALSO RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO
WANTED TO THE RISE IN THE GERMAN
IN MEMORY OF KATHY LYNCH- YOU
KNOW THOSE WHO KNEW AND- AND
WORK WITH KATHY. KNEW THAT SHE
WAS A FIERCE AND EFFECTIVE.
ADVOCATE SHE A FORCE TO BE
RECKONED WITH- IF SHE HAD A
ISSUE SHE WAS PUSHING YOU KNEW
SHE WAS GOING TO. SHOW UP IN
YOUR OFFICE AND YOU SHE WAS
GOING TO BE PREPARED AND SHE
ALWAYS HAD. A LOT OF
DOCUMENTATION I CAN RECALL
GETTING. YOUR LOTS OF PAPERWORK
THAT WAS BE LEFT WITH ME- AND
SAY HEY READ UP ON THIS BEFORE.
YOU KNOW THIS BILL COMES UP- AND
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING
WITH KATHY. YOU REPRESENT A
RURAL DISTRICT BUT ALSO IS BEING
VICE CHAIR. OF WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE AND THE KATHY WOULD
ALWAYS. BE IN THERE SHE WAS.
VERY BIG ADVOCATE. FOR THE
OUTDOOR RECREATION SECOND
AMENDMENT AND HUNTING
COMMUNITIES. AND TOGETHER WE
TACKLE ISSUES FROM CONSERVATION
. TO OFF ROAD VEHICLE
LEGISLATION. NOSE WAS SAID CATHY
WAS REALLY A TRAILBLAZER SHE
STARTER OWN FIRM IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE LYNCH AND ASSOCIATES
- AND ALWAYS HAD A REPUTATION OF
BEING EXTREMELY HARD. AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE SHE KNEW HER
ISSUES BETTER THAN ANYONE. WHEN
SHE WORKED VERY EFFECTIVELY WITH
LEGISLATORS REGULATORS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. ONE THING THAT
PEOPLE MAY NOT KNOW ABOUT KATHY
IS SHE WAS AN ACTIVE LEADER WITH
MANY ADVOCACY COALITIONS IN FOR
A LONG TIME. SHE MAINTAINED HER
PASSION FOR NURSING SHE HAD A
NURSING DEGREE. BY PRACTICING AS
A CORONARY CARE NURSE AT A LOCAL
HOSPITAL ON WEEKENDS. SHE HAD A
BIG HEART THERE WAS AS BIG AS
HER PASSION. FOR POLITICS IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PUT INTO WORDS WHAT
. HER LOSS MEANS TO THOSE WHO
KNEW HER IN THIS CAPITAL
COMMUNITY WE ARE TRULY
HEARTBROKEN. SHE WAS TRAGICALLY
TAKEN FROM US ALL TOO SOON. WE
CERTAINLY IN THIS COMMUNITY OF
HAD. TOO MUCH TRAGIC- HEART
BREAKING EVENTS HERE. BUT SHE
WAS AN EXAMPLE VERY AND GENUINE
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE LEGACY WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPACT THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY IN OUR WORK
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR A
LONG TIME TO COME I AM TRULY
GRATEFUL FOR THE TIME THAT I.
HAD WITH KATHY IN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HER
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU
MISS GALLAGHER. AND DOCTOR WOULD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF DR
RICHARD WAYNE BACHMAN WHO PASSED
AWAY ON SUNDAY MARCH TWENTIETH.
IS HOME IN SEBASTOPOL JUST DAYS
BEFORE HIS SIXTY NINTH BIRTHDAY
. WAS KNOWN TO MANY AS DR B. AND
RICK OR RICKY TO HIS FRIENDS.
RICK WAS A FRIEND OF MINE AND AN
AMAZING AND COMPASSIONATE
VETERINARIANS. WHO ALSO
SPECIALIZES SHELTER MEDICINE.
AND IMPROVING ACCESS TO SPAY AND
NEUTER SERVICES. HE RECEIVED HIS
VETERINARY LICENSE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND- THE PRIVATE
PRACTICE IN CINEMA COUNTY. OF
THROUGHOUT HIS PROVIDED SERVICES
IN SEVERAL COUNTIES HE STARTED
HIS CAREER AS A BET ON A CATTLE
. NEAR TO. HE WAS OWN BOSS FOR
MOST OF HIS CAÑADA CAREER
INITIALLY OWNING NORTHTOWN
ANIMAL HOSPITAL IN SANTA ROSA
FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS WHICH IS
WHERE I MET HIM. RE MY DOG LEASE
OF THE HIM FOR THE FIRST TIME
WAS A WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE.
RECOMMEND WE SAT DOWN ON THE
FLOOR TO GREET HER AND DID HIS
EXAMINATION THERE. ALTHOUGH LISA
THOUGHT IT WAS PLAY TIME. WITH A
NEW FRIEND. THIS WAS QUITE
ACCIDENT PRONE STORE VISITS WERE
FREQUENT WE GOT TO KNOW RICK
REALLY REALLY WELL. HE WAS A
SKILLED SERVICE SURGEON AND
NEVER SHIED AWAY FROM
CHALLENGING CASES. DURING HIS
CAREER HE SAY MANY ANIMALS TEAM
ON SALEABLE BY MANY. IS ALSO
DEDICATED TO EDUCATING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF VETERINARIANS AND
VET TECHNICIANS. HE WAS AN
ADMIRED MENTOR TOOK MANY
COLLEAGUES AND STUDENTS. AND ONE
WHO WAS SAID HIS SET AND ONE WHO
SAID HE WAS A GOOD MAN WHO
BROUGHT GOOD PEOPLE TOGETHER TO
DO GOOD THINGS. LATER IN HIS
CAREER STARTED HIS OWN PRIVATE
CONSULTING PRACTICE SHELTER
MEDICINE SUPPORT. AS DIRECTOR OF
SMSC CONTRACTED WITH BOTH
MUNICIPAL ANIMAL AGENCIES AS
WELL AS NONPROFIT ANIMAL WELFARE
GROUPS TO DESIGN. DEVELOP AND
MANAGE THEIR MEDICAL PROGRAMS.
HE WAS INFLUENTIAL IN DEVELOPING
AND GROWING SHELTER MEDICINE
PROGRAM'S IN CINEMA. NAPA CONTRA
COSTA IN LAKE COUNTY'S.
CALIFORNIA WAS ALWAYS HIS HOME
BASE BUT DOCTOR BUCKMAN'S WORK
IN ANIMAL WELFARE ALSO HAD AN
INTER INTERNATIONAL IMPACT. FROM
HIS WORK IN INDIA ROMANIA
ETHIOPIA NICARAGUA AND MEXICO
RESISTED PRIMARILY WITH SHELTER
OPERATIONS AND SPAY AND NEUTER
SERVICES. HE ALSO PROVIDED
VETERINARY CARE TO ANIMALS
AFFECTED BY DISASTERS AND
WILDFIRES INCLUDING THE VALLEY
FIRE IN LAKE COUNTY. IN NINETEEN
NINE WAS AWARDED SHELTER
VETERINARIAN OF THE YEAR FROM
THE AMERICAN HUMANE SAYS A SOCIO
HAITIAN. IN ADITION TO BEING A
GREAT BETTER VETERINARIAN HE WAS
AN AVID RUGBY PLAYER THROUGH
COLLEGE IN YEARS AFTER OFTEN
TRYING TO BURY HIS BOOTS ONLY TO
DIG THEM UP AGAIN. FOR THE NEXT
SEASON FOR ONE LAST GAME. HE
PLAYED WITH. MANY WILL REMEMBER
RICK AS A ONE OF A KIND
INDIVIDUAL A MAN WHO LIVED LIFE
ON HIS OWN TERMS. WOULD DROP
EVERYTHING TO HELP A FRIEND OR
FAMILY MEMBER IN NEED. I HOPE
WHERE HE IS NOW THAT HE'S
SURROUNDED BY A LOT OF HIS VERY
FRIENDS ALL THOSE THAT HE TOOK
CARE OF US FOR SO MANY YEARS. HE
WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HIS
DAUGHTER ANNA. SURVIVED BY HIS
DAUGHTER GAIL HIS WIFE PATTY AND
HER TWO CHILDREN. ABBY AND
ANDREW AS WELL AS CHERISH FREE
FRIENDS LEFTY SIR AND STANDING.
I ASKED WE ADJOURN INDUCTIVE
OFFICE MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THESE BRING THE NAME
SUGGESTS TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY APRIL FIFTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY APRIL SIXTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY APRIL
SEVENTH. THE FLOOR SESSION IS AT
NINE AM ALL OF THE ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SENATE HEARING OVER THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN MR WARD MOVES AND
MISS DAVIES SECONDS. THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY APRIL THE SEVENTH AT
NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.